was doing the thing where he was like
you know the island boys i mean i kind
of think that they're like viral
geniuses and i was like no they're
idiots they're like the dumbest
[ __ ] i ever met and then they
saw it which somehow in my head at that
moment i felt like oh i'm a i'm i'm
talking to another white guy it's like
there's no hip-hop people watching this
i can say whatever i want i can be
totally honest and then wow right i mean
yeah that's that it's it's kind of like
saying that ashley simpson was uh
a
genius for all the publicity she got
getting caught lip-syncing on saturday
night live right yeah people love to lay
that motive down and be like oh look
they were trying to make this happen
people love the idea of conspiracies
rather than just acknowledging that like
a lot of things are random and if they
happen in a specific order then
odd results might occur or things that
are beneficial might occur because like
i had a dude like basically try to rob
me and like stick a gun in my face
and and everybody thought it was fake
because i didn't get shot and then what
do i do afterwards i go and do logan
paul's podcast and i'm on the news and i
get all these positive things happen
from it so people thought i had to have
made it up because nothing bad happened
from it and it's like no i was just
taking advantage of the opportunity did
you see your life flash before your eyes
when that happened because you looked
and you thought it was it was like three
seconds so i didn't really have time to
think of anything besides like is this a
joke like that's what i thought like
[ __ ] joke i thought it might have
been one of my friends [ __ ] with me i
heard about that
and then like and i'm like driving to
come see him like like i said i was uh
typed in adam 22 documentary
you know when you scroll through the
youtube feed like without actually
clicking on the video it'll like play it
in place
i one of the one of the videos did and
like the little section of the the video
that played in the feed was you reacting
to the guy with the gun on you right and
i thought to myself man
like it's so crazy how the
instinct kind of takes over to like put
your hand out like that you know this is
not a good way to stop a bullet yeah
like well that's how you know it's
self-defense when they're doing like the
first 48 because there's bullets through
the hand like it's like right right it's
just like that because that's your
reaction what defensive wounds are more
like with knives and stuff but yeah
but yeah it's crazy how your instinct is
to put your hand up to stop a bullet
yeah it's uh
it's not it's definitely changed a lot
and then and then and seeing that i
thought man like
like how would i respond like i got to
believe i would like just anybody would
would react the same way like just like
you know the natural
it occurred to me that there's no cool
there's no way to look cool when someone
pulls a gun on here
and imagine if i got my [ __ ] head
blown off what that clip would have been
like
it would have been the craziest [ __ ]
thing that might have ever happened on
the internet of like seeing a [ __ ]
influencer get their heads shot up on
like on live stream like that almost
happened and also the other part of why
it was so crazy is because by the time
the guy is near me
the guy who was doing security for us
has his gun out and basically has it
pointed out the guy's head now why he
didn't pull the trigger
very controversial but
whatever he had the gun pointed at him
so i'm kind of like
feeling like i'm about to get murdered
and then also feeling like i'm about to
see this guy get murdered so there was
so much going through my head and then
somehow it ended up with him just
getting stomped out and yeah
did that go to court or anything or that
just got handled on the side so yeah the
cops ended up coming they [ __ ] scrape
them up off the ground and take them
away and at one point you know i get
contacted where they're like
you we want you to come to court
and i'm thinking about it and i'm like i
had just been talking to logan paul who
i don't know why i've said his name
three times in the last like five
minutes but i was talking to him and he
told me
about the situation he's like my advice
press charges because he had like one
dude like pull up to his crib like 10
times or some [ __ ] like like when i went
to logan paul's house he had [ __ ]
security outside like he's not [ __ ]
around at all because he's had crazy
fans show up so many times he told me
he's like when it comes down to it press
charges because otherwise this
motherfucker's gonna keep coming back so
i'm like all right that makes sense so
then when they tell me to go to court
i'm like i'm not gonna blow this off i'm
actually gonna go i had to wake up at
like 5 30 in the morning so i could be
downtown at like 7 30 or whatever and
then i'm sitting in the courtroom i see
the [ __ ] kid he's like sitting a few
rows in front of me with his dad his dad
is giving me a dirty look as if i did
something to him and then
whatever like we're sitting there
eventually the [ __ ] court appointed
lawyer or whoever the [ __ ] it was comes
over and just basically tells me like
hey this is this is postponed so you
don't have to do anything i'm like oh
and they're like
and we're not to call you back like we
don't need your help anymore i'm like
why this is the dumbest thing ever i
should have just [ __ ] ignored this
like i would have done dude it's crazy
so did he get in trouble is that
i don't even know attempted murder is
that the charge but it was a fake gun
oh [ __ ] that was a crazy part yeah
like when someone someone mentioned that
to me and yeah they said that this viral
video of someone pulling a gun on adam
22 and that they described it as it
being like super beneficial to you like
that being the point at which he really
blew up ah i mean honestly that was a
couple years after like the soundcloud
rapper wave which is when i first really
blew up is like i interviewed uh xxx
centastion and laura
and all these people who just became
[ __ ] gigantic like around that time
that was when like things really started
going crazy this was a couple years
later and again like it was kind of
convenient because the business and
everything was slowing down a little bit
around that time it wasn't necessarily
as huge as it was like maybe a year
before and it did like bring a ton of
attention but also it was like you get a
lot of attention like that month and
then like the next month you're like
back to normal like that kind of [ __ ]
when you go super viral for something
how many of those people are going to
actually be like tuned in to watch your
[ __ ] every week like
best case scenario you have that kind of
thing happen to you and you can maintain
and like capture a bunch of that
audience but that's why when people were
like thinking it was fake i'm like you
really think that
i would fake that and risk my reputation
of being and be known as a liar forever
for what for like maybe five or ten
grand extra on youtube ads that month
like that doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
yeah it's uh i've always felt super
strongly about not faking [ __ ] and you
just read like that's
from what i saw just that that like you
said three seconds and i saw it like i
was just repeating that three seconds
that red very real dude yeah
you're not you're not faking it like
that
you know i mean why would somebody i
even respect the [ __ ] out of it that
you've got that footage of like yeah
this is how that that being is so real
i almost finished because like okay that
what we were doing is like when there
was the youtube adpocalypse in 2018 i
don't know if you were here really but
we i mean i was already like
like not bad friendlies right but we
like i i remember right when that
happened i was making maybe like 50
grand a month off youtube just putting
out so much [ __ ] and all of a sudden it
became five grand a month and that's
when i was like oh [ __ ] like i gotta
actually figure out all these other
revenue streams that i haven't really
like touched on yet like we got to start
being more serious about merch and we
got to be more serious about like i i
had heard about people streaming and i
was like well maybe i can just stream
and so i start streaming and then people
start being like yo here's 10 bucks
listen to my song and i'm like all right
well he gave me 10 bucks i gotta listen
to a song that like spiraled out of
control to the point where i was like
all right i got to charge more i started
charging like 50 or 75 to 100 bucks like
to listen to their song and it just kept
coming in and all of a sudden i was
making like almost 100 grand a month off
just listening to people's music on live
stream like a hundred bucks at a time
which that is a thousand songs a month
which sounds [ __ ] kind of depressing
to listen to that many [ __ ] random
soundcloud rap songs but that was what
saved me when the adpocalypse happened
and that's exactly what i was doing when
the guy came in with the gun is i was
sitting in the back of the store with a
couple people smoking blunts and
watching [ __ ] uh people's music
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first books five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude